hi it's Michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry PhD and acne prone
skin owner at the end of July this year
I went to Jakarta Indonesia to
participate in Jakarta X Beauty thank
you so much to Female Daily Network who
run this event for sponsoring me and
collaborating on this video
Jakarta X Beauty is a three-day event in
Central Jakarta that brings together
brands, beauty content creators and
beauty lovers the event was spread
across three venues with 120 brands
participating there's lots of shopping
deals and promotions there's also loads
of interesting talks with over 80
speakers participating this year I did
two talks one was on hyperpigmentation
with Kae we talked about the difference
between brightening and whitening and
how to safely even out your skin tone I
also did a talk about acne with Dr
Arini we talked about different types
of acne what contributes to acne and how
to treat different types of acne as well
one of the things we talked about was
how to squeeze a pimple properly or by
properly we mean with the least amount
of damage because officially you
shouldn't squeeze your pimples you
should go to a dermatologist who can do
it properly with the least amount of
risk because if you don't squeeze a
pimple right it can lead to scarring and
further infection but of course we live
in the real world where people squeeze
their own pimples we can't all just wait
the three-month waiting time to go to a
dermatologist sometimes you just can't
help yourself so here's how to do it
with the least amount of harm so this is
a harm minimization video for what to do
if you must squeeze your pimples firstly
you want to make sure you're squeezing
the right types of pimples and what this
means is waiting till the pimple comes
to a head with visible pus
if there's no visible pus you're
squeezing hoping that something will
come out there might not actually be
anything in there to come out and so
you're just squeezing and causing extra
damage for no reason
secondly this is pretty obvious but you
should do it hygienically you are
opening up a wound on your skin and so
you
want it to be as clean as possible what
this means is clean skin and clean
fingers to clean your skin you should
wash it and then wipe it with alcohol to
clean your fingers obviously you need to
wash your hands you can also wear gloves
and you can also cover your fingernails
with a bit of tissue and so that gives
you a better grip as well you can also
use cotton buds instead to do the
squeezing the next thing you want is to
lance your pimple before you squeeze it
and what this means is to stab it with a
needle so that there's a passageway for
the pus to come out the needle should be
sharp so that you make a hole as small
as possible without causing extra damage
from pressure the needle should
obviously also be clean so you can use a
brand new needle out of a sterile
package you can also sterilize a needle
yourself so for example you can pass it
through a flame and wipe it down with
alcohol so here's something that was new
to me you should lance your pimple at
an angle if you stab it straight down
what you might be doing is introducing
pus at the surface deeper into the
pimple you want to lance it add an angle
or even better horizontally so that
there's no chance of the pus going
deeper into uninfected skin when you're
squeezing you don't want to use too much
pressure if you use too much pressure
you're causing extra damage that's
unnecessary with squeezing your pimple
you should stop when clear liquid or
blood comes out when all the pus is out
finally once you finish squeezing wipe
it off with either a clean piece of
tissue or even an alcohol pad and you
can also cover it up with a bandage for
example a hydrocolloid bandage to stop
any extra infection going into your
freshly cleaned pimple so those are our
tips on squeezing a pimple I hope you
enjoyed this video if you did please hit
like and subscribe to my channel you can
also follow me on Instagram and check
out my blog for more beauty science let
me know what you want me to talk about
next time
and I will see you later don't squeeze
too much